[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le mercredi 12 avril voici le programme
de ce soir il devait décoller ce matin
aux alentours de 8h30 le Nano satellite
inspire set seven conçu par le
laboratoire atmosphère et observation
spatiale plus connue sous le nom de
l'Atmos est une nouvelle fois restée à
terre cela fait déjà environ cinq fois
que son lancement est repoussé alors
pourquoi sa mise en orbite ne cesse
d'être reportée quelles sont les
conditions nécessaires de son départ
nous ferons le point avec Philippe
kekette le viste président de
l'université de Versailles
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et Mustapha
mefta le responsable du programme
satellite et comme chaque mercredi nous
parlerons aussi de cinéma dans votre 7 8
quels sont les films à ne pas manquer
cette semaine au programme donjons et
des voleurs une adaptation du fameux jeu
de rôle fantasy mais aussi une histoire
d'amour et une comédie française avec
Franck Dubosc 10 jours encore sans maman
ce sera avec notre journaliste Céline
Charles et enfin même si le printemps se
fait attendre il n'est jamais trop tôt
pour rêver de vacances et de farniente
la semaine dernière nous vous avons
donné des conseils de professionnels
pour avoir un beau jardin fleuri ce soir
nous nous intéressons à son ameublement
quels sont les tendances de cette année
pergola à Mac ou encore chaise longue il
n'attendent que le retour des beaux
jours et on le disait à l'instant il
devait se lancer à la base en janvier
2023 le lancement d'une nano-satellite
inspire 7 seven ne cesse d'être reporté
pour rappel il s'agit d'un anneau
satellite conçu par le laboratoire
atmosphère et observation spatiale le
l'Atmos qui est situé à Guyancourt et là
pour objectif d'observer le Soleil et la
Terre et de rapporter des informations
sur le réchauffement climatique
notamment mais après le 12 après le 2 le
9 le 11 et le 12 avril ça date de mise
en orbite est une nouvelle fois reportée
au vendredi 14 avril pour en parler avec
nous Philippe kekut le président de
vice-président de l'université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
bonsoir bonsoir et Mustapha mefta le
responsable du programme petit satellite
bonsoir bonsoir alors première question
comment est-ce que vous expliquez ces
multiples reports
alors moi ce que je peux dire c'est que
on a l'habitude des reports parce que on
envoyait une fusée là plus de 5 ans de
satellites on fait attention à ce qu'il
n'y ait aucun problème alors après il y
a chaque fois il y a des multiples
problèmes alors je pense que je vais
laisser mon collègue en parler parce que
c'est lui qui en direct en contact pour
les différents les différents aspects
techniques et donc là il y a un aspect
voilà particulier aujourd'hui alors oui
par rapport au report comme le dit
Philippe c'est assez compliqué il y a
aussi une conjoncture qui est liée aux
événements à l'événement bon typiquement
SpaceX a mis en orbite des satellites
militaires pour l'armée américaine le 2
avril 2023 et la conséquence c'est qu'il
faut repérer la zone de récupération
parce que la particularité des lanceurs
SpaceX c'est que le premier étage j'ai
récupéré donc première chose c'est
l'actualité et ensuite les événements
les événements ça peut être la météo et
dans notre cas de figure pour le dernier
report donc le lance devait avoir lieu
le mardi 11 avril et une anomalie a été
détectée une anomalie sur un connecteur
ou un élément et ça ça entraîne
automatiquement un report pour le 14
avril et là maintenant bon pour nous
c'est de regarder ce qu'il se peut se
passer au niveau de la météo c'est un
autre paramètre c'est la température la
vitesse des vents hygrométrie on aura
l'occasion d'en parler un peu plus en
détail dans quelques instants avec nous
également deux journalistes de la
rédaction de TV 78 Gabriel Gontier et
Céline Charles bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir
alors Céline comme d'habitude le
mercredi vous nous présentez les sorties
ciné de la semaine à ne pas manquer de
quoi est-ce que vous allez nous parler
ce soir et bien comme vous l'avez dit on
parlera de l'adaptation de ce jeu
mythique Donjons et dragons mais aussi
d'une comédie française avec Franck
Dubosc et on finira avec une romance
d'Alexis Michalik et donc ce sera enfin
démission restez bien avec nous Gabriel
vous vous allez nous présenter les
informations à retenir aujourd'hui dans
les Yvelines ce sera dans quelques
instants ants mais avant je vous propose
de jeter un coup d'oeil à la météo de
demain
[Musique]
demain matin le temps sera nuageux sur
l'ensemble des Yvelines nous devrions
avoir tout de même quelques éclaircies
au niveau des températures il fera 5
degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie Versailles et
Houdan et 4 degrés à Rambouillet dans
l'après-midi le temps devrait se gâter
prévoyez quelques averses pour le
restant de la journée côté température
il fera en moyenne 11 à 12 degrés et
demain nous fêterons la sainte Ida le
point maintenant sur l'information dans
les Yvelines
et donc c'est avec vous Gabriel Gontier
on commence ces informations du jour par
une nouvelle journée de mobilisation
prévue demain contre la réforme des
retraites tout à fait Mathilde à
l'approche du verdict de la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel une nouvelle
journée de mobilisation
interprofessionnelle est organisée
demain alors dans les Yvelines la
circulation des trains sera légèrement
perturbé sur les lignes J et elle des
perturbations sont à prévoir sur la
ligne N et U comptez 3 trains sur 4 côté
RER même tendance pour les usagers des
ligneux A et B le trafic devrait être
quasi normal pour le RER C compté deux
trains sur trois des perturbations aussi
du côté des écoles le stupeflu 78
principal syndicat dans l'éducation a
réaffirmé par dans sa mobilisation pour
la journée de demain 12e journée de
mauvaise mobilisation et cette
mobilisation pourrait se poursuivre
selon la décision que rendra le Conseil
constitutionnel vendredi lundi prochain
on va parler maintenant d'une
application qui pourrait justement vous
être utile au quotidien mais aussi
pendant les perturbations liées au
transport oui demain démarre la campagne
d'incitation au covoiturage et à
l'utilisation de l'application réseau
mobile COP alors c'est une application
libre et gratuite l'événement il est
organisé par l'association poussive et
jusqu'au 16 avril ça se passe sur les 31
communes de la Communauté coeur
d'Yvelines alors l'application elle se
décline en deux offres pour l'auto-stop
et pour le covoiturage en 2019 la
communauté de communes de cœur divine
avait mis en place plus de 160 points
d'arrêt matérialisés il y a donc de quoi
faire quand on sait que le covoiturage
est économique et qu'il permet aussi de
créer du lien social et alors est-ce
qu'en passant par l'application mobicoop
les utilisateurs sont éligibles à la
prime de 200 euros du gouvernement oui
complètement aussi bien pour les longs
trajets que pour les plus courts vous
pouvez vérifier votre éligibilité dès
maintenant direction Montesson à présent
samedi dernier avait lieu la remise de
cartable numérique à 183 élèves de CM1
oui la commune est la première ville des
Yvelines à équiper ses élèves de CM1 de
cartable numérique alors les cartables
numériques c'est quoi ce sont tout
simplement des tablettes équipées d'un
clavier s'est mis en place par scène et
Yvelines numériques pour déployer 7
outils l'âge des enfants et leur
développement a été pris en compte des
points importants une étude publiée ce
matin par santé publique France révèle
que les enfants de 2 à 50 passent plus
de plus en plus de temps devant les
écrans ce qui entraînerait au des
risques cognitifs on écoute le président
de senevelyne numérique
2 qui est donc avant le CM1 cycle
d'apprentissage le cycle 3 démarre au
CM1 CM2 et se termine en 6e donc c'est
vrai que équipé juste à partir de la
sixième on était vers la fin du cycle 3
ça nous permet dès la CM1 de commencer à
le cycle d'apprentissage et et que
chaque élève puisse aussi la connaître
mieux se servir à vivre des gens en 6e
avec un outil péd logique déjà maîtrisé
pour être encore plus performant alors
ces tablettes elles ont plusieurs rôles
éducatifs mais aussi celui de réduire
les inégalités au niveau de la
technologie et de son accès ses
tablettes elles permettent aussi de
réduire considérablement le poids des
cartables avec les manuels notamment on
va maintenant parler d'une cérémonie qui
a mis les Franciliennes à l'honneur hier
soir avaient lieu la 5e édition des
Trophées
Île-de-France 2023 oui la cérémonie
avait lieu à Paris présidé par Valérie
Pécresse la Présidente de la Région
Île-de-France elle a récompensé les
Franciliennes qui œuvrent en faveur
d'une société plus juste et innovante à
leur parmi les nommer desiblinoises 5
prix ont été remis dont le prix Simone
Veil 2023 qui récompense la Francilienne
de l'année remis à Charlotte à l'eau
alors parmi les nommés dans cette
catégorie Julie chapon originaire de
Verneuil-sur-Seine et Julie chapon c'est
la fondatrice de l'application Yuka qui
permet de scanner les produits
alimentaires ou les produits de
cosmétiques pour obtenir des
informations sur leur
notamment on continue avec une
information qui va nous mettre l'eau à
la bouche Gabriel oui il n'y aura pas de
finale pour Anthony potra à la Coupe de
France de Burger mais livelinois fini
tout de même troisième meilleur d'Île de
France c'est pas rien mais vous pouvez
trouver ce burger à quelques pas d'ici
le restaurant
up to you c'est dans ce restaurant qu'il
travaille se situe à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux oui je me suis
déjà rendu dans ce restaurant mais
j'avais pas commandé le burger donc
faudrait y retourner vous nous parlez
maintenant Gabriel d'un dispositif pour
le bien-être animal oui la mairie des
clés sous bois lance sa carte urgence
animale pour toutes les personnes vivant
seule avec un animal alors cette carte
elle permet de prendre en charge un
animal quand son maître est hospitalisé
sur cette carte c'est assez simple la
personne peut noter les numéros de deux
ou trois personnes à contacter en cas de
besoin alors cette mesure elle s'inscrit
dans le cadre de la politique de la
ville en faveur des personnes isolées de
quoi rassurer les propriétaires
d'animaux et bien merci beaucoup Gabriel
Gontier pour toutes ces informations
et puis vous aussi comme d'habitude si
vous voyez une information ou une image
qui vous a marqué près de chez vous
n'hésitez pas à nous la partager en
utilisant le hashtag 7 8 news
[Musique]
on en parlait en début d'émission le
lancement d'une nano satellite inspire 7
7 à une nouvelle fois été repoussée
conçue par le laboratoire atmosphère et
observation spatiale le à laboratoire
atmosphère et observation spatiale oui
le l'Atmos il a pour objectif d'observer
le Soleil et la Terre et de nous donner
des informations sur le climat et
notamment sur les réchauffements
climatiques mais ça date de mise en
orbite ne cesse d'être reportée pour en
parler avec nous Philippe quétude le
vice-président de l'université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et
Mustapha mefta le responsable du
programme petit satellite alors inspire
set seven devait se lancer ce matin aux
alentours de 8h30 que que s'est-il passé
pourquoi pourquoi est-ce qu'il ne s'est
pas élancé
alors on peut dire c'est que le
satellite il dépend de la fusée et lui
il est il est dans sa coiffe lui il ne
bouge pas donc lui il attend d'être
éjecter donc c'est la fusée elle-même
qui qui a bon qui a eu un problème pas
majeur mais voilà c'est l'habitude alors
on entend pas parler mais ça existe
toujours là c'est un défaut technique
qui est mineur
en début de séance bon à un moment une
série de tests est mis en place pour
vérifier que tout normalement doit bien
se passer et là une anomalie une
anomalie a été détectée alors vous savez
parfois on nous avons des informations
qui correspondent à des réponses
précises et puis à d'autres moments il y
a des choses qui peuvent être un peu
plus confidentielles liées à des
activités de sécurité ou de défense
nationale notamment pour les Américains
parce que la particularité de ce
lancement c'est que on va se rappeler
que du coup la fusée est lancée d'une
base militaire en Californie donc pour
le précédent satellite on nous avons
fait un lancement depuis la Floride
c'était le 21 le 24 janvier 2021 avec le
lancement du vsq7 et pour ce tir nous
partons depuis une base militaire en
Floride donc ça Vandenberg et c'est
environ à une centaine de kilomètres au
nord de Los Angeles alors pour la petite
histoire quand même un autre satellite
française a été lancé depuis cette base
un des premiers satellites français qui
s'appelait FR1 il avait été lancé en
1965 donc c'est une longue histoire
entre la France et les États-Unis
d'Amérique vis-à-vis notamment de ce
genre de coopération dans la mise en
orbite de satellites donc là a priori il
s'agirait d'un problème technique venant
de SpaceX de la fusée SpaceX
et d'ailleurs ce que peut rajouter c'est
cuvsq7 qui a été envoyé en 2021 donc et
qui va fonctionner avec inspire ça de 7
donc pour nous c'est important a été
repoussé aussi trois fois donc voilà on
n'est pas dans dans un actualité qui qui
met en doute notre programme c'est
relativement habituel alors bon ça met
toujours de la tension parce que voilà
un lancement satellite c'est toujours
voilà un peu à Paris au décollage en la
mise en orbite qui sont des phases
toujours critiques alors est-ce que vous
pouvez quand
même un satellite puisse bien décoller
avec une fusée
la première chose c'est de c'est de
développer ce satellite qu'il devienne
performant et qu'il respecte certaines
conditions bon une des conditions c'est
la tenue au vibration ensuite la tenue à
l'environnement en température et après
il y a une grosse partie associée à la
législation donc un départ premier
paramètre pour nous c'est le droit le
droit spatial et pour nous c'est un
satellite donc français donc on doit
respecter la législation française dès
lors on se met en accord avec SpaceX
pour répondre à une multitude de
paramètres pour que le satellite puisse
être mis en orbite on le livre aux
États-Unis et ensuite on est en attente
alors quand même une petite
particularité dans le cas de SpaceX
c'est qu'il lance une multitude disons
une multitude de lanceurs et depuis le
début de l'année ils ont déjà fait plus
d'une quinzaine de lancement donc des
décalages sont possibles initialement ce
lancement comme vous l'avez dit en début
de séance c'était prévu en janvier 2023
donc pour nous c'est trois mois de
décalage et c'est très difficile pour
les équipes parce que on s'est beaucoup
de stress beaucoup de tension donc pour
ma part ce sont des des échanges la nuit
vu que nous avons 9 heures de décalage
et typiquement pour le pour le lancement
on a du mardi 12 avril bon moi j'ai eu
l'information à 4h du matin et puis
c'est difficile de prévenir les
personnes donc j'ai attendu le matin
pour annoncer la la quelque part la
mauvaise nouvelle les gens étaient un
peu déçus parce que tout le monde veut
voir à un moment cet événement et puis
bon par ailleurs c'est aussi très bien
de le voir sur place parce que assistant
lancement en direct c'est c'est autre
chose alors pour la mission de ce
satellite est-ce que ça va changer
quelque chose qui soit envoyé trois mois
plus tard ou
ça ne va rien changer au final
je peux répondre et puis que tu veux on
peut partager tous les deux la réponse
bon pour nous plus vite c'est lancé
mieux c'est parce que nous avons déjà
notre satellite qui en orbite et le
satellite USA a été développé
initialement pour avoir une durée de vie
d'une année donc comme vous l'avez vu ça
fait plus de 2 ans que ça en orbite donc
c'est quand même une réussite pour le
laboratoire pour la recherche françaises
et aussi pour le territoire parce que
nous avons poussé un nombre
d'entreprises du territoire pour pouvoir
réaliser cet instrument le deuxième à
partir du moment où il est mis en orbite
il faut aussi que le premier reste
vivant le plus longtemps possible et
avec deux satellites on est en train de
mettre en place une constellation puis
je vais laisser mon collègue donner la
suite parce que ça va nous intéresser au
niveau des variables climatiques
essentielles que l'on cherche à observer
notamment pour de la multi-mesure oui
parce que ce qu'il faut voir c'est que
scientifiquement le fait qu'on est comme
ça des constellations c'est on apporte
beaucoup plus que avoir un seul
satellite aujourd'hui on a besoin de
précision on a besoin de résolution
spat mal temporelle et donc un passage
ne suffit pas il faut il faut pouvoir
avoir plusieurs satellites alors bien
sûr celui-ci est envoyé dans une orbite
différent donc ils m'ont pas passé au
même heure et vont compléter ce que
faisait le premier satellite et donc ça
ça va être une première c'est vraiment
de montrer que un plusieurs satellites
scientifiquement apporte plus
aujourd'hui on est dans une dans une
course quand même sur les problèmes
climatiques et notamment de comprendre
des cycles courts parce que même si
c'est le climat en fait finalement les
processus ils sont ils sont courts et
régionales donc il faut qu'on puisse
voilà pavé l'ensemble du alors ce qui
est bien c'est que le satellite qu'on
envoie il couve la terre entière il
s'arrête pas lui il tourne mais il en
faut plusieurs pour pouvoir voilà avoir
heure par heure ce qui va se passer quoi
qu'est-ce qu'il va apporter concrètement
comme information pour
en termes d'information plus plusieurs
paramètres vont nous intéresser donc
déjà un des paramètres qui est
fondamental c'est le déséquilibre
énergétique de la terre comment la
planète accumule de l'énergie donc il
faut savoir que la majeure partie de
l'énergie est accumulée dans les océans
donc c'est important de savoir quelle
énergie nous accumulons et comment à un
moment nous allons évoluer vers par
exemple meilleure connaissance de la
température pour les 50 à 60 prochaines
années donc l'intérêt des satellites
c'est de faire des mesures précises pour
consolider des modèles climatiques et à
partir du moment où les modèles
climatiques sont mieux maîtrisés on a
une meilleure idée des températures à
venir donc ça c'est l'aspect
modélisation et l'autre paramètre ça va
être l'atténuation quelle solution nous
allons pouvoir mettre en oeuvre pour
pouvoir répondre à ces problématiques
donc ça c'est indépendant du programme
un autre c'est par exemple d'observer la
ionosphère d'une sphère c'est une des
couches de l'atmosphère donc mieux
comprendre ce qu'il peut se produire en
termes de perturbation donc pour cela
nous avons une coopération avec l'ONERA
qui a un grand organisme des plus grands
organismes au niveau aéronautique et
spatial en France
qui va étudier ces phénomènes et c'est
important pour les perturbations au
niveau des communications vous avez vu
que nous sommes de plus en plus dans un
monde hyper technologique alors ça a des
gros avantages mais aussi des fragilités
parce que nous sommes tributaires de ces
technologies et si pour X raisons si par
exemple nous avons une grosse tempête
giovannity nous ne savons pas prévenir
ce genre de problème on peut avoir une
baisse ou une coupure de communication
donc c'est aussi important au niveau
local et régional d'avoir ces
informations ce qu'on peut ajouter quand
même malgré tout c'est ce que c'est que
la ionosphère la une sphère c'est cette
zone où circule justement les satellites
donc c'est en ça que c'est critiques
parce que effectivement si vous
satellites dysfonctionnent
tout le monde va s'en apercevoir on aura
plus de téléphone on aura plus de télé
on aurait pu grand chose voilà
aujourd'hui on est quand même très très
dépendants de la technologie et donc
avoir ces épisodes ça permet d'anticiper
de couper ponctuellement certaines
connexions et de préserver du coup les
satellites dernière question est-ce que
l'actualité
à la géopolitique à jouer un rôle aussi
dans le report du lancement de ce nano
satellite la réponse c'est probable
alors nous nous sommes des chercheurs et
des scientifiques
forcément je pense notamment aux
tensions entre Taiwan
nous avons devoir de réserve vis-à-vis
de certaines informations évidemment que
certains événements peuvent introduire
des problématiques on peut vous parler
de brouillage ou de oui c'est possible
de ce qu'on peut dire c'est que
globalement je penétique nous impacte de
toute façon puisque le spatial c'est
quand même une affaire très
internationale et alors même si nous là
sur ces sur les projets dont on parle ce
sont des périodes relativement courtes
les autres projets ce sont des projets
effectivement à 10 ou 20 ans donc voilà
des projets avec la Russie on en avait
beaucoup et donc voilà il y a des
impacts forcément quand ça devient plus
compliqué voire pour l'instant très
compliqué
et bien merci beaucoup Philippe
quéquette et Mustapha mefta d'avoir
accepté notre invitation suivra donc de
près le lancement de l'inspire stats
seven il devrait s'élancer ce vendredi
14 avril d'une base américaine militaire
en Californie on va donc croiser les
doigts pour que tout se passe bien
sur YouTube sur quelle chaîne Youtube du
coup le l'Atmos celle du Atmos
on reste à peu près dans le secteur
puisque jeudi dernier l'Université de
Versailles Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
organisé une conférence sur les droits
des femmes la thématique un corps à soi
le droit des femmes d'hier à aujourd'hui
au total trois femmes ont pu apporter
leur expérience professionnelle devant
les étudiants en écoute aujourd'hui Gada
Hatem gangster gynécologue
obstétricienne et fondatrice de la
maison des femmes à Saint-Denis au micro
de Céline Charles
[Musique]
je m'appelle Rada Hatem je suis
gynécologue à coucheur et j'ai fondé la
Maison des Femmes en 2016 dans ma
pratique et donc notamment dans cette
maison des femmes
c'est un accueil inconditionnel pour
toutes les femmes vulnérables et
victimes de violences on les reçoit on
les soigne on soigne leur corps on
soigne leur psyché on essaie de les
aider sur le plan social juridique
économique
expérience de médecin un peu engagé dans
le droit des femmes et notamment tout ce
qui concerne leurs droits à disposer de
leur corps puisque en tant que
gynécologue se sont nos sujets pouvaient
intéresser ces étudiants qui sont
majoritairement des étudiants droits et
effectivement il y a une grande
corrélation entre médecine et droit
notamment sur ces sujets
[Musique]
le droit des femmes à disposer de leur
corps est en droit assez récent qu'il
est encore assez fragile questionné dans
beaucoup d'endroits de la planète on a
de la chance en France les mouvements
féministes ont des marées il y a plus de
100 ans et alors ils ont été inégaux ils
sont variables il y a un million de
façon d'être féministes mais ce qui est
certain c'est que si ça n'avait pas
commencé il y a 100 ans on en serait pas
là aujourd'hui il y a eu énormément
d'acquis ces cinq dernières années alors
que pendant des millénaires la culture
patriarcale était la culture dominante
aujourd'hui elle est questionnée alors
peut-être que le balancier va aller un
petit peu trop loin c'est normal
j'espère qu'on va surtout trouver un
équilibre et que cette nouvelle
génération sera celle de cet équilibre
[Musique]
allez c'est l'heure à présent d'ouvrir
une large culture
[Musique]
et on commence avec de la musique et
plus particulièrement de rap électro
mais également d'écologie les trois
réunis ça donne le we are festival ça
aurait lieu samedi prochain et cette
organisé par deux associations de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye anywise et la clé
pour en parler avec nous Mathieu Poiré
bonsoir alors vous êtes le président de
l'association anywilde anywhilde comment
ça se trouve anywise alors première
question Mathieu Poiret alors c'est quoi
l'électorat parce que les deux ça se
conjugue bien
alors déjà sur la création de ce
festival c'est vrai qu'on a tout de
suite parti sur ces deux styles de
musique
aujourd'hui
dans dans le rap on retrouve beaucoup de
touches électro et puis même inversement
donc c'est pour ça que voilà on a on a
choisi aussi nos artistes pour
construire notre notre line-up autour de
ces deux styles et puis c'est aussi de
styles qui sont très très écoutés auprès
des jeunes et donc comme notre festival
est quand même à destination
majoritairement des jeunes c'est
important pour nous de retrouver ces
deux styles de musique
majoritairement des jeunes on imagine
avec l'Europe mais est-ce que ça attire
aussi des personnes un peu plus
âgées finalement que vous attendiez pas
alors on n'est pas fermé à avoir plus
que des jeunes bien sûr ça tout le monde
peut venir tout le monde est bienvenu
nous l'objectif surtout c'était
d'attirer des jeunes c'était surtout
pour leur parler en fait écologie leur
parler développement durable parce que
du coup l'association anywise c'est une
cible qu'on touche beaucoup avec qui on
a envie de parler moi pour ma part j'ai
18 ans donc c'est vrai que c'est
beaucoup plus simple de parler aussi
avec des jeunes de certaines thématiques
et de passer à l'action le principe de
ce festival du coup c'était vraiment
voilà de se dire je viens un festival
engagé je viens pour m'amuser parce que
je suis jeune et j'ai envie de m'éclater
c'est ça tout à fait alors justement
votre association animale elle défend la
cause environnementale ou peut-être vous
pouvez peut-être nous parler de cette
association quelles sont les causes que
que sont les actions que vous mettez en
place concrètement quelle est la
démarche
c'est une association que j'ai fondée il
y a 5 ans maintenant on était au départ
de 6 potes on va dire à se dire on a
envie de faire une action on a envie de
faire quelque chose à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye pour agir et donc
tout de suite on a créé donc une
association
et on a été accompagné d'ailleurs par la
ville de Saint-Germain-en-Laye mais
aussi la clé qui nous accompagne au-delà
du festival sur l'association depuis un
petit moment maintenant c'est
l'association du coup autour du
développement durable l'idée c'est
d'aller voir les jeunes on part du
principe que maintenant on est à peu
près tous au courant que on est dans une
situation complexe donc là l'idée c'est
surtout de se dire comment on passe à
l'action de nos thématiques du coup
alors c'est évidemment on va dire du ce
qu'on appelle nous du basique opération
de nettoyage de sensibilisation etc etc
mais on a une thématique aussi qui nous
tient particulièrement à coeur et qu'on
aimerait beaucoup plus développer c'est
les comptes que c'était cette peur
vis-à-vis des problèmes environnementaux
et sociaux donc voilà et puis on a lancé
aussi très récemment une friperie
solidaire par exemple l'idée voilà c'est
d'apporter des vêtements que nous on
revend à très très faible coût pour
financer les projets de l'association et
en même temps ça permet à tout le monde
de pouvoir
s'habiller avec ses moyens on va dire et
donc ce samedi
dans cette même lignée comment est-ce
que ça s'est fait comment est-ce que
vous êtes dit bon ben on va créer un
festival qui va mêler la musique et puis
l'écologie
c'est une histoire qui est un peu assez
marrante il y a 3 ans on s'est dit on a
vraiment envie d'organiser un événement
pour pour des jeunes justement mais pour
parler environnement on sait très vite
aperçu que ça allait être compliqué
d'attirer les jeunes si on fait juste
des conférences c'est juste des ateliers
donc on s'est dit on s'est dit on va
rajouter le côté musique et en plus bah
nous personnellement l'équipe on allait
beaucoup en festival aussi donc c'est
aussi une ambiance qu'on avait envie de
retrouver à Saint-Germain-en-Laye donc
du coup voilà on s'est dit voilà il faut
mélanger les villages et en même temps
la partie musique on s'est rapproché de
la clé qui tout de suite à sauter dedans
parce que c'est un projet qui est qui
est super cool et en même temps qui est
super fédérateur donc au départ on avait
voilà nos deux structures et en fait
petit à petit on a été rejoint par plein
d'autres structures à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye c'est un festival
qui se veut très très local sur les
partenaires villages mais aussi sur sur
certains des artistes qu'on a aussi
qu'on a aussi choisi
du coup voilà donc ça fait trois ans
qu'on travaille dessus il y a eu des
échecs évidemment ça fait partie du jeu
et nous aussi le but c'est d'apprendre
d'apprendre le métier de producteur
d'apprendre le métier de programmateur
etc etc donc du coup voilà là on a on va
dire la meilleure version de ce qu'on de
ce qu'on pouvait imaginer sur we are
festival vous parlez d'un festival et
d'écologie ça me fait penser au festival
we love green qui a été critiqué l'année
dernière par rapport à l'impact
écologique pendant le festival notamment
les nuisances sonores par rapport aux
animaux c'est des choses que vous avez
pris en compte aussi pour votre festival
oui alors Willow green serait qu'au
départ on a fait une grosse veille
documentaire autour de ce festival pour
savoir comment il s'est construit
comment aujourd'hui il a envie de se
développer nous on est parti du principe
qu'on s'établissait d'abord une espèce
de charte éco-responsable à respecter au
maximum pour pouvoir voilà construire le
festival et par exemple on a aucune
musique à l'extérieur donc voilà le parc
de la clé mise à part un petit fond
sonore au niveau de la restauration
c'est tout ce qu'on aura même nos
conférences ne seront pas pour sonorisé
donc voilà
mais après voilà cette charte elle va
aussi sur la restauration par exemple
vous parlez driver green c'est vrai que
aussi sont pas mal investi là-dessus
nous aussi on essayait de faire au
maximum
mais cette charte elle va aussi
s'établir sur sur les transports sur la
santé voilà plein de choses comme ça
alors on va parler un petit peu de la
programmation est-ce que vous pouvez
nous parler un peu des des artistes qui
seront présents alors les artistes qu'on
a qu'on a choisi on a d'abord du local
du très très local on commence par
exemple avec Denise qui vient de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye qui est un jeune
DJ de 19 ans voilà donc ça c'est sa
première scène en festival après on a la
117 parties qui est un donc un groupe de
trois jeunes rappeurs pareil donc
Saint-Germain-en-Laye trap et puis Paris
si je dis pas de bêtises donc voilà
l'idée c'est donc trois styles de rap
aussi bien à eux et voilà ils vont jouer
tous ensemble pendant une heure et après
du coup on arrive sur nos trois têtes
d'affiches qui n'ont pas été choisies au
hasard puisque ces trois têtes d'affiche
par exemple donc on a deux DJ Azz dek et
bastric et un rappeur STO mais STO a
déjà collaboré avec azdek par exemple
bastré que joue aussi des mélodies qui
sont électro mais qui sont aussi rap
donc voilà finalement ils savent jouer
les deux et c'est pour ça que on a aussi
un lien et une harmonie entre les deux
styles de musique toute la soirée
tu as déjà fait d'ailleurs Lola palosa
et puis l'électrique Park qui a été à
château dans les eaux
électrique Park en septembre dernier
donc voilà quand même et puis STO qui
commence à bien se faire entendre lui il
vient de Lille mais quand même comment
savoir une bonne communauté aussi donc
c'était important de ramener ce genre
d'artiste à Saint-Germain-en-Laye de
pouvoir voilà les ramener dans des
endroits où vous pourrez pas
habituellement les voir
et du coup globalement ce sont des
artistes engagés pour la cause
environnementale
c'est une très bonne question
pour cette première édition on n'a pas
pu malheureusement bien bien creusé
certains points même si il a fallu faire
des choix que ce soit au niveau de
logistique mais même budget donc voilà
maintenant sur est-ce que les artistes
sont engagés j'espère que
personnellement ils sont engagés
maintenant voilà on n'a pas non plus
pris un artiste qui va faire des photos
sur Instagram très limites ou ce genre
de choses quoi on essaie de faire aussi
attention à ça
il va s'agit d'une première édition vous
attendez à peu près combien de personnes
alors on est à ça d'être complet et les
informations ce matin donc on est sur
une salle de 220 places voilà il doit
rester peut-être une petite quarantaine
de places voilà sur les trois jours qui
restent à devrait vite partir et bien
merci beaucoup Mathieu d'avoir accepté
notre invitation donc si vous êtes
intéressé il reste encore quelques
places le we are festival se tiendra ce
samedi 15 avril à la clé à
saint-germain-en-lay début des
festivités 14 heures et début des
concerts 18h allez c'est l'heure de
parler cinéma à présent on commence avec
le coup de coeur ciné d'un professionnel
du 7e art ce soir c'est le réalisateur
yvelinois Benjamin palier qui nous
partagent son coup de coeur pour le film
à mort l'arbitre on replonge dans les
années 80 regardez
[Musique]
cette semaine je vais vous parler du
film à mort l'arbitre qui a été réalisé
par Jean-Pierre Mocky en 1984 avec comme
comédien principaux Eddy Mitchell et
Michel Serrault alors pourra vous
raconter un peu l'histoire du film donc
en fait c'est une course poursuite entre
des supporters d'une équipe de foot et
l'arbitre du match qui les arbitrer
juste avant
donc en fait ça se déroule sur une
soirée une nuit entière les supporters
vont courir après l'arbitre durant toute
la soirée il va y avoir des drames
durant cette soirée
je voulais parler de ce film parce que
je pense que Jean-Pierre Mocky est un
réalisateur dont on parle pas assez
c'est un réalisateur indépendant qui a
fait beaucoup de films en se
débrouillant par lui-même en trouvant
des financements trouvant des
producteurs et trouvant des comédiens
qui souvent jouaient bénévolement
ce film a pas rencontré un grand succès
en salle puisqu'il a fait peut-être
100000 100000 entrées au box-office mais
par la suite donc 20 ans après quand il
est passé à la télé il y a eu beaucoup
de personnes qui ont regardé ce film
notamment un journaliste de Libération
qui à l'époque à l'époque disait que ce
film était une satire vraiment flippante
et toujours d'actualité du fanatisme de
certains supporters donc voilà je vous
conseille d'aller le voir si vous n'avez
jamais vu de films de Jean-Pierre Mocky
je pense que c'est l'un des films
références de ce réalisateur
[Musique]
et on poursuit cette page cinéma avec
les films à ne pas manquer cette semaine
c'est avec vous Céline Charles et ce
soir on commence par une adaptation
celle d'un célèbre jeu de rôle oui
Mathilde est autour du plateau vous
connaissez peut-être donjon et dragons
un des plus anciens jeux de rôle de
fantasy avec ses figurines de monstres
et de guerriers et bien il fait son
grand retour au cinéma après les
catastrophes industrielles des premières
adaptations cette fois-ci le spectateur
va se retrouver plongée au cœur d'une
aventure épique dans laquelle une bande
de voleurs va se battre pour retrouver
une relique mythique un film bourré de
l'humour au casting 5 étoiles Crispin
reggaempêche ou encore you grand dans le
rôle du méchant un film comme je l'ai
dit avec beaucoup d'humour qui
correspondra aux fans comme aux moins
avertis regardez pour tout dire
on m'a aidé qui fallait pas à voler ce
qu'il fallait pas
on pensait pas libérer la plus grande
force maléfique que le monde est connu
mais on va arranger ça d'accord et
comment on va faire
on en discute autour d'un verre
pour avoir une chance de gagner on aura
besoin de force tu vas assurer vaut
mieux si on compte sur toi
on aura aussi besoin de courage
de magie
et de toi
on continue c'est sorti ciné avec un
autre rendez-vous Céline 10 jours encore
sans maman c'est la suite d'une comédie
sortie en 2020 exactement 3 ans après le
succès de 10 jours sans maman réalisé
par Ludovic Bernard Franck Dubosc et de
retour en paire de famille débordée tout
avait pourtant bien commencé pour
Antoine sa femme et ses quatre enfants
il devait partir en vacances en famille
10 jours à Courchevel mais c'est à la
dernière minute qu'Antoine se fait
planter par sa femme Isabelle pour cause
d'urgence professionnelle il va devoir
assumer ses 10 longs jours de galère
tout seul regardez
elle va pas nous faire le coup deux fois
[Musique]
une minute à moi là
un homme quatre enfants et des skins
comédie rafraîchissante avec un vrai
discours finalement sur la charge
mentale dans les familles et on termine
votre sélection Céline avec un film
d'Alexis Michalik le réalisateur porte
sa pièce une histoire d'amour à l'écran
et oui comme son titre l'indique c'est
un film qui parle d'amour un sujet qui
ne s'épuise jamais une histoire d'amour
c'est celle de Katia et Justine de femme
qui tombent rapidement amoureuses et
pour qui tout semble évident dans cette
vie qui paraît
idyllique elle décide d'avoir un enfant
mais lorsque Katia tombe enceinte par
insémination Justine s'en va brutalement
12 ans plus tard Katia alors mère d'une
jeune fille apprend qu'elle est
condamnée par la maladie elle va trouver
en son frère un écrivain cynique et
désabusé un tuteur d'urgence dans le
même temps Justine refait surface un
film qui vous fera passer du rire aux
larmes en arrière de temps merci
beaucoup Céline Charles alors comme
d'habitude petit tour de plateau est-ce
que vous avez une préférence parmi les
trois films
peut-être une histoire d'amour j'ai vu
la bande-annonce que c'est pas très
joyeux je pense mais
le réalisateur s'est assuré de pas faire
un film un peu mélo dramatique il a
vraiment voulu que ça soit un peu un peu
un peu vivant et vous Mathieu poires qui
a une préférence grand fan de la série
stranger things sur Netflix forcément
dangereux et dragons ça me tente pas mal
quoi moi j'avoue que les trois films
m'ont donné envie d'aller les voir au
cinéma mais oui peut-être une préférence
pour Donjons et Dragons j'aime bien ce
style d'humour avec beaucoup
d'autodérision alors on continue de
parler de on va parler de printemps et
de jardin maintenant dans le 7 8 même si
le Printemps met un peu de temps à venir
les températures sont encore un peu
fraîches et le soleil se fait attendre
il est temps de s'occuper de son jardin
si vous avez la chance d'en posséder un
mais alors comment l'aménager on fait le
point tout de suite
[Musique]
la semaine dernière nous vous donnions
des conseils de professionnels pour
semer et planter et avoir ainsi un
jardin fleuri cette fois-ci nous nous
sommes intéressés à l'ameublement
pergola chaise longue ou encore serre
les Yvelines étaient invités à découvrir
les nouvelles tendances le week-end
dernier au salon art et jardin à la
Bergerie Nationale de Rambouillet le
reportage de Mélanie poquet et Julien
Leroy jardin passion jardin détente lors
de cette troisième édition du salon art
et jardin à la Bergerie Nationale de
Rambouillet ce samedi 8 avril
professionnel de l'aménagement et
artisan d'art s'était donné rendez-vous
pour présenter les dernières tendances
de mobilier extérieur pergola chaise
colorée ou hamac un lieu de vie majeur
dans le cœur des Français avec le retour
des beaux jours et la pièce principale
de ma maison faut que ce soit joli c'est
comme à la maison la décoration c'est
important depuis la crise du covid 19
cette professionnelle remarque un regain
d'intérêt pour l'aménagement extérieur
du jardin elle propose du mobilier sur
mesure avec du bois résineux résistant
intempéries le pince et le matériau
qu'on va décliner sous toutes ses formes
c'est à dire pour de la terrasse la
pergola de la bride des carpors c'est le
matériau qu'on va retrouver le plus chez
nous donc il est traité traité autoclave
il est fait pour être en extérieur cet
artisane crée des décorations en verre
pour le jardin et note l'importance du
public pour la personnalisation de cet
espace chez moi j'ai l'impression c'est
vraiment le coup de cœur qu'ils accroche
et puis que les interpellent et pour se
faire plaisir et qui donne le petit côté
rigolo à leur jardin ce sont des polos
qui ressemblent beaucoup à Shadok mais
ce sont pas des Shadoks on peut les
accrocher à l'intérieur ou à l'extérieur
et les pics de jardin pareil c'est la
technique du fusing de verre ça c'est la
technique Tiffany du vitrail dans le
jardin des Français les cernes sont plus
simplement utilisés pour cultiver depuis
quelques années cette entreprise réalise
50% de ses ventes pour l'habitat des
particuliers ils peuvent y installer un
salon et profiter de la chaleur ambiante
les gens recherchent un produit joli de
bonne qualité des choses qui avec style
verrière avec des petits carreaux des
soubassements avec des coloris un petit
peu tendance pastel selon une étude de
l'Ifop 2022 cette Français sur dix
possède un jardin et 72% d'entre eux
prennent plaisir à l'entretenir
et c'est bientôt la fin de cette
émission mais juste avant de se quitter
un petit mot de sport aujourd'hui dans
le si on parlait sport présenté par
Michael elmidoro ses chroniqueurs sont
revenus sur les performances contrastées
du Football Club de Versailles le FCV de
voilà Ligue 2 s'éloigner après 4 contre
performances en écoute tout de suite un
extrait alors on va parler football dans
cette thématique et du FC Versailles
dans le championnat de National les
versaillers n'y arrivent plus dans cette
fin de championnat quatrième match sans
victoire les hommes de cris sont
arrachés le match nul dans le temps
additionnel sur la pelouse du stade de
briochin grâce à Gustave acouston le
score un but partout au classement les
joueurs de la cité royale ne sont plus
les favoris pour l'accession en Ligue 2
ils sont pour l'instant à la cinquième
place à quatre points du leader
Martigues la question sur cette
thématique la montée en Ligue 2 est-elle
inaccessible oui ou non
non
compromise n'est pas inaccessible alors
pierre vous étiez un peu entre les deux
entre les deux c'est le terminal qui est
par définition par définition peut-être
pas peut-être pas évident dans cette
question là mais c'est surtout sur le
sur en fait sur l'histoire du FCV en
National on a suffisamment parlé l'an
dernier de l'épopée et des promesses du
FCV là c'est c'est plus le FCV promu en
National qui redevient promu et qui à
nouveau connaît une saison qui qui
semble qui semble au départ promise
promise au promus sur la dernière série
je crois sur les six derniers matchs
c'est trois nuls de défaites une
victoire là on est plus sur on est plus
sur un sur un rythme de prétendant à la
montée en Ligue 2 de surcroît qui est
quand même un sacré un sacré Gap et
c'est cette impression vous l'avez
rappelé que que Versailles n'y arrive
plus
on en parlera sans doute de savoir si
les querelles extra sportives ou les
problèmes extra-sportifs n'ont pas rongé
le groupe de l'intérieur mais là en tout
cas il y a plus les recettes qui
fonctionnaient qui fonctionnaient pour
le SCV en début et en milieu de saison
toujours c'est question aussi de match à
domicile qui ne sont pas vraiment des
matchs à domicile les les perspectives
de le rapprocher au stade j'envoie ils
n'ont pas à Versailles et donc bon c'est
quasiment spectateur
sans assistance donc il y a pas de il y
a pas de douzième homme voilà et c'est
là c'est simplement constaté avec avec
un petit peu de déception ou de
tristesse par rapport aux attentes qui
n'étaient pas prévues au début de saison
et qu'on a commencé à avoir au fur et à
mesure des victoires mais bon là là on
va dire pour rester positif que que le
promu et c'est maintenu et que
maintenant a priori il est il est loin
peut-être de la marche de la marge de la
montée c'est pas impossible et
mathématiquement ça vient de plus en
plus difficile genre qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez
je suis un petit peu comme Pierre voilà
cette montée alors moi non je n'y crois
plus c'est fini pour vous
j'ai pas fini parce que ce sportivement
on peut pas dire que c'est fini moi ce
sera c'est pour ça que j'ai dit j'ai dit
non aussi parce que
inaccessible non on peut s'il y a
toujours une pourcentage de qui fait
qu'ils peuvent monter mais qui est
faible mais c'est pas trop au niveau des
résultats c'est la manière donc la
manière là là le le on dirait que il y a
le ressort un petit peu cassé
sportivement et là ça gagne plus ça
gagne plus et il y avait cette spirale
de victoire de début de saison qui
faisait que là on commençait à rêver on
commençait à rêver déjà la montée de de
monter on parlait alors que on l'a dit
souvent sur ce plateau mais un club qui
monte et qui est promu généralement on
la première le premier objectif c'est se
maintenir consolider pour après préparer
la marche supplémentaire et la montée là
de suite on s'est on s'est vu à espérer
de suite la montée et puis envisager des
belles choses et devenir une grande
équipe dans la cour des grands là je
crois que ben il y a quelque chose qui
s'est cassé le ressort est un petit peu
pété et il faudra peut-être revenir sur
des objectifs normaux comme on l'a dit
Pierre tout justement c'est un club
promu on va faire une belle saison parce
que pas non plus
du premier donc on peut pas dire on peut
pas dire c'est catastrophique au
contraire c'est une très belle saison
c'est une très belle saison et il faut
justement tirer les bénéfices et non pas
à dire ah ben non c'est foutu on montera
pas oui mais c'était un luxe imaginez si
Versailles se monte cette saison ce que
ça peut engendrer avec ne serait-ce que
l'histoire du stade ne serait-ce que ça
et si vous voulez regarder l'émission en
entier elle sera disponible dès ce soir
sur notre chaîne YouTube bientôt la fin
de ce 7 8 mais avant de se laisser les
prévisions météo de demain
[Musique]
demain matin le ciel sera nuageux sur
l'ensemble des Yvelines ne devrait même
avoir tout de même quelques éclaircies
au niveau des températures il fera 5
degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie Versailles et
Houdan et 4 degrés à Rambouillet dans
l'après-midi le temps devrait se gâter
prévoyait quelques averses pour le
restant de la journée et côté
température il fera en moyenne 11 à 12
degrés et c'est la fin de cette émission
merci pour votre fidélité je vous
souhaite une belle soirée sur TV 78
prenez soin de vous
[Musique]